[Musik]
Land und Brecht
schönen guten Morgen schönen guten
Morgen guten Morgen guten Morgen unser
dritter Videopodcast unser zweiter mit
Gast und einer auf den ich mich sehr
sehr freue Richard Thomas Kister ist
heute bei uns zu Gast wir haben der
Einfachheit halber abgemacht wie duzen
uns einfach Thomas und ich kenne uns
schon eine ganze Weile Thomas Kistner
sehr geschätzter Kollege von der
Süddeutschen Zeitung der sich intensiv
und ganz ganz lange mit Fußball und
allgemein und im speziell mit der FIFA
beschäftigt
ist auch ein guter Moment quasi Halbzeit
Halbzeit Bilanz bei der WM in Katha muss
erstmal die Runde fragen ihr guckt
ich gucke ja nicht jedes Spiel ja genau
aber jetzt ab Achtelfinale und so weiter
schon etwas häufiger Thomas auch ich
muss ja
allerdings nicht mehr im Stadion ja okay
bevor wir gleich reingehen Richard ich
wir haben uns schon mal drüber
unterhalten du sagtest du warst mal bei
der FIFA ohne es zu wissen ja in der
Kantine ja
ich war in Zürich eingeladen von der Uni
Zürich ich hatte damals einen Vortrag
und organisiert wurde das von so einem
Spenden Förderer Freundeskreis der Uni
und dann hieß es wir gehen jetzt
Mittagessen und mir war da nicht so
richtig klar ich dachte das ist ein
Restaurant und dann kamen wir da nicht
habe ich auch gewundert also oberhalb
des Sieges ganz toll gelegen ja und dann
hätten wir zwei Sachen aufgefallen also
das eine in der Kantine was mir auch
viele war dass sie da so eine Attrappe
hingebaut haben sonst so ein Weltpokal
wo ich dann dachte mir das auch komisch
dass man das so darf sowas alles
lizensiert oder so ja war natürlich der
echte richtig klar
profitiert wie viel Trüffel das auf die
Nudeln gab also das war mehr Trüffeln
als Nudeln also ich habe noch nie ich
dachte was ist das für ein Restaurant wo
so viel Trüffeln darüber gerieben werden
naja und das dritte vielleicht was mir
auch hier war würde ich mich dann so
umguckte wird also an den anderen
Tischen saß das waren keine Frauen drin
das waren ausnahmslos Männer
ältere Männer und alles schlecht
gelaunte Männer also das hatte schon so
diese Atmos noch wieder Atmosphäre so
ein bisschen Tanz der Vampire und dann
die Zusammensetzung von allem dreien hat
mir dann doch klar gemacht ja noch
Nachfrage wo ich denn hier eigentlich
bin großartig das war dann tatsächlich
bei der FIFA vielleicht gerade Medien
gelesen ja ja Süddeutsche gelesen aber
das mit dem der Weltpokal war echt ja
ich nehme an das ist das Original also
ich weiß nicht ob die eine kleine
Kantine stehen haben oder ob der
Aufbewahrungsort die Kantine ist also
heute zumindest nicht mehr ich weiß
nicht wie es damals war ja ist jetzt
aber acht Jahre her den Service haben
die mindestens fünf
bevor wir gleich einsteigen waren die
Geschichte der FIFA und die hatten ganz
großartiges sehr langes Recherche
intensives Stück zu dem Thema gemacht
Thomas
eine Frage für mich als jemand der sich
mit Fußball nicht so gut auskennt aber
was mir auffällt ist es gibt bei dieser
WM unfassbar viele Millimeter
Entscheidungen und dann ganz lange
Beratungen und danach Spielzeiten von 7
8 9 10 11 12 Minuten ist euch das auch
aufgefallen was passiert da
das ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt es
ist zum einen ein Novum noch nie ist
eine Weltmeisterschaft so von
Schiedsrichtern bestimmt worden die noch
dazu nicht sichtbar sind das ist der
sogenannte Vase dieser Video assistant
der da irgendwo im Keller sitzt und sich
die Bilder immer wieder anschaut bei
strittigen Szenen und in der Tat ähm es
ist auffallend wie oft das passiert es
ist auffallend wie knapp die
Entscheidung immer wieder sind denn wir
haben zum ersten Mal hier ständig
Zentimeter und sogar Millimeter
Entscheidungen Stichwort japantor gegen
gegen Spanien das für das aus der
deutschen gesagt hatte und wir haben
interessanterweise auch immer wieder
Schiedsrichter die
sichtlich genervt zum Video
rauslaufen dann sind einbestellt werden
und die auffallend oft irritiert ratlos
mit sich selbst kämpfen und auf dem
Platz ja genau
zurück haben was gesehen und machen dann
dieses Zeichen und so entschlossen
Rennen genervt raus und kommt zurück als
hätten das verfaultes
Gefühl
[Gelächter]
das heißt dieser dieser alles
entscheidende Keller oder was das ist
diese mächtiger als der Schiedsrichter
die können denn sagen komm mal her bei
dieser Weltmeisterschaft bestimmen die
das was auf dem Platz vor sich geht und
hinzu kommt natürlich ein
sehr kritisches Element da sitzen noch
drei Mann drei offizielle mit drin das
sitzt also sitzen sieben Leute in diesem
bildschirmraum das sitzt einmal der der
Video Assistent dann hat er wiederum
drei weitere Assistenten in der Regel
kommen die aus allen Welten Regionen und
ich weiß nicht wie die damit andere
kommunizieren aber
irgendwie muss das auch noch
funktionieren und dann sitzt noch drei
offizielle der FIFA Match Director und
alles mögliche wahrscheinlich noch
derjenige der die Kaffeesahne
aufplustert und die quatschen da ja alle
durcheinander nehme ich mal an und
werden damit Handzeichen der
Entscheidung fällen oder wie muss man
sich das nein die sind ja verbunden über
den Kopfhörer mit dem Schiedsrichter
kriegt dann aber von denen gesagt also
wir sehen das so ja dafür muss vorliegen
diskutiert wenn die Szene entsprechend
Strate es gibt natürlich auch Dinge
warum macht man das so kommt
ich frag mal direkt ja in Kenntnis der
handelnden Personen und der handelnden
Organisation Thomas elstus für möglich
dass gerade bei diesen
millimeter-entscheidungen dass dann
nicht alles unter Umständen vielleicht
und möglicherweise mit rechten Dingen
zugeht
halte ich für durchaus möglich denn bei
der FIFA bei dieser FIFA muss man zum
einen wirklich mit allem rechnen es gibt
hier
Probleme in allen Bereichen zum anderen
müssen wir mal grundsätzlich festhalten
dass das natürlich von enormer Bedeutung
ist was auf dem Rasen abläuft
da finden auch letzten Endes dann die
die Dinge statt die für die künftigen
Geldverteilung wichtig sind ja also das
ist schon von von großer Bedeutung
beispielsweise das unterstellt dass die
FIFA
parteiisch ist in der Frage wer weiter
kommt und zwar abhängig von was das
unterstellt dass es nicht die notwendige
Transparenz gibt
dass wir jetzt hier sitzen können
beispielsweise und sagen können es ist
definitiv so es ist nachweislich so dass
hier nur völlig objektive Kriterien
greifen das ist nicht der Fall das sehen
wir an den Vorgängen die wir bisher
schon erlebt haben beispielsweise das 3D
Bild dieses berühmte 3b das dann am Ende
einer Entscheidung kommt wenn dann noch
mal vorgespielt wird okay hier das war
abseits und dann werden zwei Spieler in
der Regel gezeigt die eben so da stehen
dass dann mit der mit der kalibrierten
Abseitslinie der Nachweis geführt wird
dass derjenige eben im Abseits stand
oder auch nicht im abseitstand ist bei
der jeweiligen Szene geht und da haben
wir schon verschiedene
Problemchen zu besichtigen seid jeder
dran an der Geschichte wir sind dran und
sind natürlich da mit mit
Wissenschaftlern die
erstmals bei dieser WM ganz genau
hinschauen und alle Spiele genau
analysieren also mit mit
Algorithmen läuft das ab also die die
schauen da nicht drauf und sagen okay
wir haben den Eindruck hier ist
irgendwas faul so kann es nicht
funktionieren sondern die gehen
nach unterschiedlichen Kriterien
gehen die auf den Wahrheit auf den
videoassistenten sie gehen auf den
Schiedsrichter und sie gehen auch auf
die Spieler mit der Kernfrage wird hier
manipuliert läuft ja irgendwas okay das
wird erfasst beispielsweise
wenn man sie Spieler nehmen da hat
glaube ich noch keine großen
Auffälligkeiten gegeben
so dass genau erfasst wird wie schnell
läuft ein Spieler in der Regel wie hoch
springt er wie attackiert er die
Gegenspieler und wenn dann eine
Situation entsteht in dem der
Verteidiger plötzlich über irgendeinem
Eckball überhaupt nicht hochgeht was er
sonst immer macht und damit eine
Situation klar begünstigt dann ähm
gebührt der Algorithmus sagen der läuft
normalerweise läuft der reagiert
normalerweise in verschiedenen also sehr
verdächtig halbverdächtig bisschen
komisch und so weiter und so setzen ein
Gesamtbild zusammen und
klar wir haben einige krasse
Fehlentscheidung im elfmeterbereich die
hat aber auch jeder gesehen bei dieser
WM
zu besichtigen aber vor allem und das
ist das entscheidende
spielt sich plötzlich das ganze
Geschehen wirklich Millimeterbereich ab
das kann das kann ja nicht sein es
spielt in millime Japan Deutschland
nach dem was wir von wissenschaftlicher
Seite mathematisch bemessen hören ist
der Ball um gut zwei Zentimeter im
ausgewiesen wir haben auch Bilder die
das zumindest für das menschliche Auge
sehr sehr nahelegen ich frage mich wie
man in dieser Geschwindigkeit
das ist so einer
irrsinnig knappen Entscheidung die
wahrscheinlich auch noch die falsche
Entscheidung war
hat kommen können umso interessanter ist
ja stellen wir mal einen Raum ist es in
der in der Eile ist Geschehens eben
passiert umso interessanter ist dass die
FIFA zumindest in den zwei Tagen danach
immer wieder Bilder nachgeschoben hat um
zu zeigen dass der Ball wirklich die
Linie nicht voll überschritten hat also
da kommt fast so ein bisschen was wie
ein schlechtes Gewissen auf also weil
der kann danach gefragt und die Bilder
sind nie wirklich aussagekräftig
so wenn man das mal wenn wir ein anderer
spielerausgang dann gewesen naja das
bedeutet Deutschland
noch so eine Entscheidung wir haben
merkwürdige 3D Bilder gesehen 3D Bilder
die sich die nicht deckungsgleich sind
mit dem
was aus dem Originalbild
herausdimensioniert wurde
wir haben auch ein 3D Bild gesehen dass
einen entscheidenden Akteur gar nicht
berücksichtigt das war gleich die
allererste 3d-entscheidung
Eröffnungsspiel als Ecuador den frühen
Führungstreffer nur drei Minuten gegen
Katar gegen Katar erzielt hatte und dann
erstmal fünf Minuten
Ruhe im Schacht war weil im media-raum
groß recherchiert wurde
ein bisschen komisches Gefühl aus und
das das Bild das am Ende gezeigt wurde
und das bis heute im Raum steht
offiziell und öffentlich ist ein Bild
von dem Ecuador Spieler der den Ball
dann gleich spielt
angeblich im Abseits und einem
Abwehrspieler der kurz hinter ihm steht
halbe Fußlänge hinter ihm da ist in der
Tat ähm Abseitsstellung gegeben was aber
nicht berücksichtigt ist ist der Torwart
von Kata der ausgesprochen kommt der
also in diesem Spieler gegen gesprungen
kommt einem vorbei springt oder
verunglückte Abwehraktion und der
löst sehr wahrscheinlich das Abseits auf
weil er springt an dem Spieler vorbei
okay und der war dann nachher in dem
Bild gar nicht zu sehen
wie um wie viel Bilder noch vorhanden
also
bei diesem
minimal minimal müsste man eben
nachmessen müsste man auch nachmessen
die Frage ist dass wir ohnehin jetzt
vielleicht mal eine gute Idee wenn sich
die ein oder andere wissenschaftliche
Institution Mathematiker Statistik und
so weiter aufgerufen fühlen mit diesen
Bildern zur hantieren eigenes Interesse
daran haben ein bisschen Wasser in den
Wein und sage also was ich natürlich
verändert hat in dem Moment wo ich diese
ultimativen Messmöglichkeiten habe
schaffe ich jetzt eine ganz andere Fähre
die ist vorher im Fußball nicht gab
genau ne und jetzt kann das natürlich
passieren dass ich trotz all dieser
Messinstrumente weil ich eine schnelle
Entscheidung gefilmt eine falsche
Entscheidung treffen kann und die
verzeihen wir dann nicht mehr dem
Schiedsrichter müssen wir das verzeihen
auch wenn wir uns aufregen und sagen ja
gut hat er nicht gleich sehen hier
erwartet man dass es 100%ig richtige
Entscheidung gibt und vielleicht führt
das trotz allem nicht zu 100%ig
richtigen Entscheidungen das wäre jetzt
sozusagen der Versuch zu sagen naja aber
es kann ja trotzdem mit rechten Dingen
zugegangen sein aber daran hast du
Zweifel aber ich kann nicht in den Raum
stellen das ist besser denn je das ist
sauberer denn je das ist präziser denn
je und mache dann Fehler
okay ich glaube da stimme ich zu wenn
[Musik]
Situationen wie eben das Tor von Japan
dabei minimal jeder wird verstehen wenn
man dann sagt okay in der wir können es
nicht eine halbe Stunde lang das Spiel
anhalten wir haben es versucht so gut
wie möglich und dann ist halt ein
Zentimeter ja versteht jeder wenn wir
jetzt mal wir können dagegen stellen die
Gemengelage bei der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft generell das
ist die 22 die wir gerade erleben es gab
einen einziges Mal in diesem bisher
abgelaufen 21 Fußballweltmeisterschaften
eine Mannschaft die nicht aus Europa und
nicht aus Südamerika kam die es ins
Halbfinale geschafft hat nicht ins
Finale wenigstens Halbfinale das war
Südkorea 2001 2002 bei der WM im eigenen
Land und gegen Deutschland rausgeflogen
gegen Deutschland rausgeflogen weil dann
die FIFA selber die Reißleine gezogen
hat und den Armen Urs Meyer damals der
bekannte Schweizer Schiedsrichter der
eigentlich schon sich aufs Finale hat
freuen dürfen
der musste das Spiel Pfeifen weil die
beiden Spiele von Südkorea vorher
erkennbar
ganz schräg gelaufen sind muss man ganz
positiv zu sagen gegen Italien gegen
Spanien haben die mit unfassbaren in
unfassbaren Situationen gewonnen der
Schiedsrichter Bayram Morino aus Ecuador
der das italien-spiel gepfiffen hatte
der ging nach Hause nach der WM hat sich
ein Haus gekauft hat sich ein dickes
Auto gekauft und einige Jahre später
wurde er mit fünf Kilo Kokain am Leib im
JFK Kennedy mjf Flughafen in New York
verhaftet also dieser Mann ein
Drogenkurier hat das WM was war es
Viertelfinale Achtelfinale gegen gegen
Italien gepfiffen und Südkorea kam durch
also das ist die die Historie und
natürlich ist es wenn ich jetzt
weltpräsident bin dieses Verbandes fällt
mir das natürlich schon mal irgendwann
auf Mensch verdammt noch mal eigentlich
reicht's aber mal hier Südamerika gegen
Europa spielen lassen am Ende kommt
immer wieder das Gleiche raus übrigens
auch jetzt wieder jetzt kann ja
das gleiche läuft da jetzt auch gerade
wieder ab also es liegt in der
natürlichen Interesse sage ich mal das
auch andere Nationen soweit wie nur
möglich kommen und was diesmal
eingetreten ist
wie auch immer ist das aller verwende im
zumindest die Unterrichte jetzt sprichst
du von einem natürlichen Interesse
Wissen natürliches Interesse ist dass
das natürliche Interesse von Johnny
Infantino und wenn ja warum das ist
natürlich Interesse von ihm ich würde
sagen auf zwei Ebenen ähm einmal ein
legitimes denn wenn ich eine Weltverband
richtig auch immer
führe dann ist es natürlich schön wenn
jeder irgendwo hingehen sowieso aber
auch mal also im Sinne von Weiterkommen
genau und zum anderen hat er natürlich
selbst in der konkreten Situation in der
er sich befindet nämlich die absolute
Spaltung zwischen FIFA und dem
europaverband UEFA das ist ja eine
vorsichtig gesagt nicht Beziehung man
könnte auch hassbeziehungen sagen
zwischen den Spitzen dieser beiden
Verbände natürlich das Interesse seine
Position politisch zu stärken in dem er
sich vielleicht irgendwann mal ist der
Präsident veranlassen kann das geschafft
hat den Rest der Welt an die
fußballspitze heranzuführen nach dann
fast 100 Jahren 1930
okay also man merkt da sitzt jemand der
sich im Bezug auf die FIFA wenig
Illusion macht ja das sollte man sich
auch keine Illusionen die vergiftete
Frage gestellt ob du glaubst dass es
nicht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist
weil der FIFA müsste ja die Frage
umgekehrt stellen also wann ist es schon
mal wieder FIFA mit rechten Dingen
zugegangen das würde wahrscheinlich die
Situation besser
weil wir heute mal die Chance haben du
bist auch ein großer Fußball Kinder
Richard ich ich höre eigentlich vor
allen Dingen nur zu Thomas der der
Experte in dem ganzen investigativen
Bereich lass uns doch mal ganz ganz
vorne anfangen wann ist die FIFA
gegründet worden und warum
1904 bin ich das richtig erinnere in
Paris naja es haben sich einiges in
Paris ja die waren und ist dann ich
glaube den 20er Jahren umgezogen nach
nach Zürich und jetzt ist ein Teil
wieder nach Paris gewandert jetzt hat
Infantino hat einen Teil schon wieder
ausgelagert zurück nach Paris und da
sitzen angeblich so um die 100 Leute 80
100 in einem Gebäude das dem Emir von
Katarina
genau ja selber lebt in Katar und ähm
ein Teil der FIFA ein weiterer Teil sein
nächstes Jahr in Richtung USA
ausgelagert werden
man könnte sich vorstellen dass er dann
da vielleicht auch noch mit hinzieht
immer wieder sozusagen die spontane
Liebe mal zur Wüste mal zur schönen
Landschaft der USA und so weiter
entdeckt man fest und dann sozusagen
diesen schönen Landschaften auch
hinterherzieht kann man das so sagen so
kann man sehen wobei die Liebe nicht so
spontan ist sondern lieber eigentlich
von Anfang an da irgendwie war von
Anfang an eine eine merkwürdige Liebe so
zu den äh damals gewählten und das kann
da lösen Umständen gewählten Verbänden
in Russland und in Katha Thomas und lass
uns doch mal bitte ich ich habe euer
euer Stück dazu wirklich großartiges
Stück habe ich schon mehrfach empfohlen
durchhocke jetzt gerne noch mal in der
Süddeutschland
so genau ein richtiges dosiert mit einem
ominösen Flug so das anfängt mit dem
ominösen Flug aber ich würde gerne bevor
wir auf diesen Flug kommen vielleicht
gehen auf 2010
Bill Clinton reist nach Zürich warum
weil er die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in
die USA holen wollte die Uhr das Jahr
2000 für jetzt 22 diese WM
stattfinden ja wir reden über den Moment
in dem diese Entscheidung diese
Fußball-WM in der Wüste von Katar
stattfinden zu lassen in dem all das
passiert ist danach große Untersuchungen
Razzien Anklagen Menschen hinter
Bettlaken ja die voll laufenden Kameras
der Weltpresse verhaftet worden sind und
so weiter das kam alles danach drei
Amerikaner gestehen dass sie geschmiert
wurden so lass uns da mal reingehen also
wirklich reist als Vertreter der USA
2010 nach Zürich
in der festen Hoffnung im sicheren
glauben dass in der Überzeugung
Fußball-WM 2022 in die USA geht genau
und dann passiert was
also die Amerikaner hatten
diese Überzeugung weil sie wussten dass
der damalige FIFA Präsident der Blatter
auf ihrer Seite war und wenn du den
Präsidenten hast hast du eigentlich
immer
die Veranstaltung im Sack weil der kann
das dann richten in diesem Fall war es
eben anders weil ähm ganz kurzfristig
Michelle platiniert damals UEFA
Präsident Frankreich
abgesprungen ist vom Laufen Zug
abgesprungen ist nachdem er mit seiner
Cousine damaligen Staatspräsidenten und
dem heutigen Emil von Kata im
elise-palast ein spontanes Mittagessen
hatte und
er ist dann abgesprungen und hat noch
zwei wahrscheinlich sogar drei weitere
europäische Wahlmänner mitgenommen
auf die andere Seite für Cutter und
damit ist das Ganze gekippt der Platte
hat noch am Abend vor der Abstimmung
telefonierten
südamerikanerne Leute gebraucht geil
die Ausgangssituation also als als
Klinken dahin reißt wie ist da das
Setting wie viele Leute sitzen da wie
viele Leute Stimmen ab wessen Stimme
geht definitiv schon nach Katar wer ist
geschmiert wer es bezahlt wer ist für
die USA
also als als Clinton ähm dahin kam hat
er sicherlich spekulieren hier wir
wissen es nicht nicht definitiv aber da
hat er sicherlich von
von der Platte der auch mit Obama
gesprochen hat im damaligen Präsidenten
die Zusicherung dass es klappt wird ne
das war auch der erklärte Plan von
Platte Russland 18 22 die USA und dann
26 China dann habe ich die große Achse
weltweit und bin reif für den
Friedensnobelpreis das war der Gedanke
dahin wirklich das ist immer der Gedanke
dahinter bei mir genauso das einzige die
hat Geld die haben macht ein Fluss ohne
Ende das einzige was sie wollen was sie
auch übrigens auch dass sie sogar mit
riesigen Premium immer wieder versucht
haben ist
Lobbying in Norwegen um diesen
verdammten Friedensnobelpreis endlich zu
kriegen und der im übrigen natürlich
auch dafür sorgen würde wenn ich den mal
habe das schreckt natürlich auch
Staatsanwaltschaften künftig
viel mehr ab als wenn ja
Motiv für dich für den
Friedensnobelpreis in Stellung zu
bringen das ist das ist ein ein ganz
wesentlicher Antrieb für diese Leute
also das ist okay das ist sozusagen die
Heiligsprechung ja okay ja
dann kommt dahin in der festen Annahme
jetzt hole das Ding um die USA und zwar
jetzt holen das endlich so dann wir
haben schon einige Male versucht
Veranstaltung zu kriegen 90
was viel einfacher
Fußballweltmeisterschaft zu kriegen und
sie
hatten da wenig Probleme okay das Ding
ist wirklich so und dann sollten
Aschenbecher durchs Zimmer geflogen sein
will Clinton war außer sich vor Wut ja
dass die Amerikaner irgendwie gelingt
worden sind genau und dann setzte etwas
ein die USA fingen auf einmal
erstaunlich intensiv an sich für
Vorgänge in FIFA zu interessieren was ja
eigentlich vorher gar nicht so ihr
großes Metier gewesen ist ja sie hat
eine ganze juristische Lawine Röllchen
bis hin zu diesem Verhaftungen im Bauer
olak genau das war ja das was man sich
als Außenstehende auch immer gefragt hat
ne warum aus genau erledigen jetzt
plötzlich die Amerikaner all das was wir
eigentlich mal hätten erledigen müssen
ich habe mich schon damals gefragt
dürfte dass die norwegische
Staatsanwaltschaft auch oder die
deutsche oder so mit mir waren die
Zusammenhänge nicht klar warum die
Amerikaner ermitteln und und ihr
beschreibt das so Thomas in dem in
diesem in diesem Dossier und sagt pass
auf das ist eigentlich sozusagen die das
letzte Lied in einer langen Kette von
Demütigungen der USA gewesen und die
Amis hatten einfach die Nase voll davon
ein uns andere Mal am Nasenring quasi
durch die Arena gezogen zu werden und am
Ende immer wieder leer auszugehen
vielleicht kannst du das mal so ein
bisschen einordnen die Chronologie
dieser Demütigungen wann beginnt die
beginnt das in New York mit dem Versuch
die Olympischen Spiele nach New York zu
holen exakt in der Nullerjahren gegen
das Los mit mit New York 2005 Hillary
Clinton war damals bei der Vergabe zu
gehen für die Amerikaner und auch in der
Bild natürlich darüber verwendet einen
großen Werber reden noch mal
vorgetragen warum das jetzt unbedingt
dahin muss und damals ist New York dann
London war es am Ende die zwei Hörspiele
ist New York in Runde 2 rausgeflogen
Runde 1 war Moskau aber mit Moskau
war eigentlich der Deal schon gemacht
ihr kriegt dafür in zwei Jahren die
Winterspiele
New York 29 Chicago Chica und dann kommt
2c
okay
richard hat das gerade angedeutet
Clinton war immer so sauer dass dann
Aschenbecher durchs Zimmer geflogen sein
sollen das ist berichtet worden aus der
Delegation
und danach danach wurde die
amerikanische Staatsanwaltschaft so
richtig heißt ja eigentlich schon am
in der Woche danach ging es los so
schnell so schnell geht das hat die hat
nur die brichterstattung die
amerikanischen aber auch die die
international weiß natürlich in diesem
Falle
so schräg war ich meine wenn wenn ein
katamizer mit mit Katha ja wenn ein Land
von der Größe Nordhessens mit der
Einwohnerzahl also native katharins von
Wuppertal
die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft an der
Südtirol wir könnten
[Musik]
die Anleitung
nehmen
dass das irgendwie schräg ist noch zu
mal ist ja auch die technischen
Bewertungen für die jeweiligen Bewerber
gibt und da hatte gleich zwei
KO-Kriterien also eines kennen wir ja
alle es war die Bewerbung wohlgemerkt
für Juli August
gewesen 45 Grad das geht gar nicht ne ja
also war klar da muss man reinschauen
und natürlich wussten sie auch durch die
Berichterstattung rund um das hier ich
meine
so wie ihr das auch berichtet auf der
Zunge mal zergehen lässt der gewinnt das
Land das bei der vorab Inspektion durch
die FIFA am miesesten abschneidet in
allen erinner
die zieht dann Blatter aus dem Umschlag
und glaubt eigentlich selber nicht so
richtig was er da liest ne ja genau
Blatter war für Amerika ne Platter
wollte die USA okay der wollte eben
Russland USA
amerikanische Oberstaatsanwältin Miss
Lynch ja wir lassen hier kein
ungeschoren davonkommen
und wie sich das für eine gute schmieren
Komödie gehört wechselt irgendwann die
Fronten und wird die juristische
Vertreterin der FIFA
das ist ähm im
Schnelldurchgang gewesen
nachfolgenden Jahre ja was passiert ist
ist natürlich die Amerikaner nicht
wahnsinnig viel Wissen angehäuft denn
was sie gemacht haben sie haben sich
erstmal ihren eigenen Mann geschnappt
der
saßen
mit dem Schlüssel
eigentlich aus dem aus dem Jugendfußball
aber amerikanischer FIFA Amerika ja
amerikanischer FIFA funktioniert der
denn
Welt den den Regionalverband
continentalverband Nord Mittel Amerika
und Karibik als Generalsekretär geführt
zusammen mit dem legendären jackwarner
das ist eigentlich der eine die
Inkarnation von sportkorruption genau
der der Vater der Mütter aller korrupten
genau
auf dem Sterbebett die Hand aufhält
würde ich jetzt nicht widersprechen
immerhin ist gerade vor einigen Wochen
sein letzter Einspruch gegen die
Auslieferung in die USA abgeschlagen
worden also es könnte passieren dass er
da noch auftritt dann werden wir
sicherlich noch ein bisschen was
erfahren über die die damaligen Umstände
denn äh jackwarner dürfte Auspacken wenn
er wirklich mal von einem amerikanischen
Richter sitzt aber sie haben also Chuck
Blazer geschnappt sie hatten einfach mal
steuerlich das ganze bisschen
durchleuchtet Blazer hat das
so albern wie es klingt ja also der
Konka Kaff Generalsekretär hat im Trump
Tower Trump Tower das kostet ein
bisschen was auch damals schon unten
irgendwo was weiß ich vielleicht 20 30
Stock die Büros seiner Konka Kaffee
[Musik]
Stelle gehabt und ein bisschen weiter
oben hat er gewohnt und die Leute ich
habe damals auch für ein Buch auch mit
jemand gesprochen der gearbeitet hatte
die haben echt großen Teil sind Trump
Tower gesessen haben Bingo gespielt am
Computer hat nichts zu tun ab und zu mal
Chuck von oben mal runtergerufen hat
gesagt der Jungs kann da mal einer
kommen ähm den Papa geil füttern oder
der hatte klein so weiß ich oben Freunde
und so weiter also das ist ähm das ist
sind die die Dienst am Fußball und ähm
ansonsten wird das drei Museen in den
Nachtclubs und solche Dinge und ähm
Blazer war also relativ leicht zu
kriegen für die Amis und
dann hat im Jahr 211 auch Jack Warner
noch selber mitgeholfen weil als die
zwei über Kreuz kam
sind plötzlich Banküberweisungen
aufgetaucht die Blazer in Bedrängnis
brachten so und die Amis haben mit ihm
Deal gemacht wie man dass er da gerne
macht dann sowas auf du kannst jetzt
aussuchen
Angebote gemacht
also entweder 35 Jahre wir haben hier
zwei Dinge für dich im Angebot und bin
wieder 35 Jahre Antwort ah oder oder
du arbeite zusammen genau und ein
Schlüsselbund genau da war dann ein
Mikrofon aber das Mikrofon und dann kam
der immer bei der FIFA in die
Besprechung war erst mal jovial sein
Schlüssel auf dem Tisch ja das hat er
vorher schon gemacht weil er war solchen
leibesfälle in diesen Jahren dann schon
mit einem mit so einem Fahrbahn und
Untersatz unterwegs
und das war so ein rit
bei allen möglichen auch bei olympischen
Besprechungen beispielsweise dann
Besprechung in London bei den London
spielen
das heißt die haben mit dem einen Deal
gemacht die haben den ganz hart unter
Druck gesetzt und sagt pass auf entweder
Knast oder Möglichkeit B du arbeitest
mit uns zusammen dann verwandt das FBI
praktisch diesen Schlüsselbund
ja und fortan sitzen die Amerikaner mit
am Tisch und hören bei allem zu und
wissen alles und hören wie die auch
sollte man meinen Geld Überzahlungen
über das kann man nur spekulieren das
kann man nur spekulieren ich glaube mal
grundsätzlich
auch nicht dass es so direkt abläuft ja
also da der hocken ja nicht sehen 12 15
Leute zusammen und reden ganz offen über
solche Dinge da die sind untereinander
oft auch Spinne vereint
Gespräch bei trüffelnudeln abfahren das
wäre genau das wäre besser oder ja
schlecht ne ich glaube da sind
ist noch bisschen mehr wenn du sagst
Thomas dass das ist nicht so wie sich
jetzt lies ihr Müller das so vorstellt
sondern das läuft anders wie läuft das
denn wie korrumpiert man die Leute wie
wie laufen die Gefälligkeiten läuft das
wirklich in Sex läuft das in Bargeld
läuft das durch andere also kommen lässt
es gibt so eine Art Handlungsanleitung
die ähm unter den Agenten kursiert die
es gibt ja ein ganzes agentenfeld
lobbyistenfeld international Leute die
ständig unterwegs sind bei Olympischen
Spielen bei
Fußballweltmeisterschaften bei
sportvergaben die einen hohen militären
Wert haben und dann auch immer wieder
angehört werden immer wieder die
gleichen Leute neue kommen dazu alte weg
aber es ist so ein ein Pool von Agenten
die da ständig machen hier sind
vorübergehend verhindert weil sie gerade
mal wieder im Knast sitzen kommt auch
vor ja dann wird es natürlich ein
bisschen schwieriger aber im Hintergrund
in dem Bereich kann ich im Bereich
Beratung ist alles möglich vor allem
auch dass die Zahlung angeht ja dann
Zweifelsfall ist es immer ein Berater
und dann kriegt er irgendwas und ja ja
da da wird mit Dossiers gearbeitet ja
also ich ich lege durch Sie es an über
die Leute die abstimmen jeweils weil nur
das interessiert also ein Privatdetektiv
guckt sich vorher an wie jemand Leben
ne die die die kennen ja auch die Leute
weil die bewegen sich rund um die Uhr in
diesem Umkreis ja die die sind immer
dabei der der der die Karawane Sport
zieht immer um den Planeten Tagung
Sitzung was weiß ich das ist ja auch mit
das Schöne daran für den funktioniert 5
Sterne Business Class
und immer dabei und da gehen die Leute
ständig hin die sitzen praktisch jeden
Abend in irgendeinerbar und sprechen
damit Leuten mit denen mit dem man
sprechen kann andere gibt es mit dem man
nicht sprechen kann aber man erfährt
natürlich über seine Leute allmählich
auch wie man an andere Leute
es geht nicht um die Erpressbarkeit weil
wenn man das einmal macht ist natürlich
dieses Geschäft ziemlich kaputt
unter vier Augen und sagt immer du hast
doch und das muss doch nicht jeder
wissen und so weiter oder ja aber das
ist riskant also man kann nicht
ausschließen dass sowas natürlich
es geht um genau es geht um die
Schwachstellen und beim einen ist es
natürlich der Koffer Geld es gibt Leute
es gibt in diesen Kreisen ja auch Leute
die sind so und ermächtlich Reich also
laufen ja
also nicht mit Geld oder mit irgend
sowas also muss man irgendwas anderes
sich da einfallen lassen und das gilt
auch für andere in diesem Geld und
Landadel der da vereint ist und
beispielsweise persönliche Neigung da
kann man auch sehr viel schöne Dinge
machen ne und bis hin zu irgendeinem der
was weiß ich seit einer Briefmarken
sammelt und schon immer hinter dieser
einen Herr ist die man aber nur über
Beziehungen was weiß ich wie auch immer
ja weil wenn man sie nicht kaufen kann
irgendwas kriegt oder sehr beliebt und
sehr unauffällig Kunstgegenstände der
kriegt ein Bild und hat es an der Wand
und wann kommt der mein Staatsanwalt auf
die Idee dahin zu gehen und einen
Kunstexperten mitzunehmen der jetzt mal
abschätzen was das Teil werden und so
weiter sondern das ist endlos dieses
Feld und das wird entsprechend natürlich
dann auch so aufgestellt ich meine jetzt
würde mich mal interessieren nachdem wir
quasi diese diese ganzen Machenschaften
da diskutiert haben die du ja über viele
viele Jahre recherchiert
wenn man jetzt tatsächlich mal in
idealistischen Ansatz fragt auch wenn
das Wort Idealismus jetzt hier sozusagen
das Gegenteil des real Praktizierenden
Pragmatismus ist wenn du jetzt die
Chance bekämest ja kriegst den Auftrag
dazu die FIFA zu reformieren ja von mir
aus auch abzuschaffen und was neues zu
gründen was müsste man eigentlich tun
und was könnte man deines Erachtens
jetzt wenn die WM zu Ende ist und so
weiter als leere daraus ziehen und sagen
wir machen das jetzt mal alles ganz
anders und ganz neu wo müsste man da
ansetzen
also man müsste sie mit mit Strom und
Stil
herausholen also FIFA und durch muss
müsste die FIFA so wie sie existiert
kannst nicht funktionieren okay das ist
ja nicht schwer die FIFA aufzulösen es
müssten ja nur alle wichtigen
Mitgliedsverbände austreten dänemark hat
ja schon auf laut drüber nachgedacht und
wenn der DFB und der englische
Fußballverband und so wenn ihr jetzt
alle Austreten aus der FIFA dann ist das
ein König ohne Land in fantino ja weil
dann kann er gar nichts mehr machen
jetzt eine neue Organisation gründen und
die dürfte ja genauso
Weltmeisterschaften abhalten die nennen
sich nur nicht FIFA Weltmeisterschaften
aber auf das Wort FIFA kommt nicht an
das stand da früher auch nicht drauf das
kommt überhaupt nicht an aber so
könnte es nicht funktionieren man muss
es immer von dem einzigen herdenken dass
wichtig ist das Geld es geht nur um Geld
und eine Reform der FIFA oder eine
Veränderung in diesem Bereich
funktioniert nur über das Geld
man würde niemals auch eine annähernd
eine Mehrheit zustande bringen um die
FIFA richtig zu reformieren geschweige
um sie abzuschaffen oder irgendwas
anderes
reden
doch es geht von innen wenn diese fünf
oder sechs das würde schon reichen
wirklich relevanten Verbände der DAB der
Englisch
[Musik]
also wenn es fünf sechs starke Europäer
werden dann könnte man auch Amerikaner
okay könnte man auch weil nämlich dann
zum einen die Sponsoren
was soll ich mit einer WM wollt wo
solche Mannschaften nicht teilnehmen und
das wird dann mit Usbekistan aufgefüllt
und warte Maler
und vor allem würde etwas in Gang kommen
was man viel zu wenig auf dem Radar hat
was wir aber schon mal erlebt haben
nämlich letztes Jahr im April als die
super Liga plötzlich kreiert wurde über
Nacht also eine m-taktik von Real Madrid
Juventus Turin Barcelona und einigen
anderen die dann mit drauf gesprungen
sind drei große Englisch Clubs oder vier
und ähm womit niemand gerechnet hatte
die waren sich ganz sicher die haben
auch enorme Schäden erlitten Juventus
ist jetzt Pleite der ganze Vorstand ist
zurückgetreten musste zurückgetreten
Barcelona hängt in den Seilen
europäischen Gerichts in wenigen Tagen
auch eine vorläufige Einschätzung geben
wie man das dann sieht beim EuGH und die
waren also ganz sicher wir reißen das
Ding jetzt hier hier raus und machen
unsere super Liga und das was passiert
was man ja künftig im Kopf behalten muss
die Fans in ganz Europa sind auf die
Barrikaden gegangen und sie haben die
Politiker vor sich hergetrieben überall
wurden Statements Abgas in allen
wichtigen Ländern wurden Statements
abgegeben auch politische Statements und
innerhalb von nur drei Tagen ist das
Ganze scheppern
und noch mal eine Woche später sind alle
bis auf die genannten drei Juventus real
und Atletico gekommen und haben enorme
Geldbußen akzeptiert und haben
unterschrieben bei der UEFA beim Europa
verbannt dass sie sich nie wieder an
sowas beteiligen werden
anders oder besser machen also damals
vor allen Dingen die spanischen Vereine
die in der wirtschaftlich unglaublich
schlecht geht das geht für Athletico es
geht für Barcelona geht für Real hat das
ganze Tafel Silber vor einiger Zeit
verkauft und inzwischen ist der erlöst
davon auch schon wieder aufgebraucht die
also gedacht haben wir können uns nur so
finanziell befreien hier geht es ja um
was anderes hier geht es ja nicht darum
dass man mehr Geld scheffeln will als
die FIFA scheffelt und hier ging es ja
darum dass man was saubere saubere
Lösung findet ich habe vor einiger Zeit
mit dominikus Skala mich unterhalten der
ja auch große Nummer bei der FIFA
gewesen ist und in diesen ganzen Spiel
ja auch eine Rolle
Compliance Chef der der FIFA okay und
der gesagt hat die ultimative Lösung
bestünde darin dass man eine
Aktiengesellschaft macht also dass der
FIFA eine Aktiengesellschaft an der wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe die
jeweiligen Verbände beteiligt sind
und dass die Vergabe der
Weltmeisterschaft an eine gesonderte von
der FIFA getrennte Firma ausgelagert
wird die sowohl für die Vergabe oder vor
allen Dingen auch für die Organisation
zuständig ist also die FIFA quasi
zerlegen so dass es nicht mehr eine
einzige Organisation ist das schien mir
jetzt mal eine interessante Idee eine
andere Richtung zu sein jetzt hast du ja
gerade überzeugend gesagt er wird die
FIFA von sich aus nicht machen bleibe
ich nach wie vor bei meiner
Lieblingsidee ja Austreten aus der FIFA
und die FIFA damit unter Druck setzen
das wäre sicherlich der erfolgreichste
Weg es ist der schwierigste weil
natürlich
wir müssen wir sehen uns am
DFB-Präsidenten an dem neuen Diskussion
über die Binde und so weiter auf der Weg
noch nicht lange dabei ist vielleicht
sogar zu kurz dabei ist das überhaupt
erst so 19 ähm im Mittelrhein Präsident
geworden und jetzt ist er ähm auf dem
Sprung in die FIFA in den FIFA Fahrrad
da hatte ich schon beworben für also ähm
es es herrscht ein dermaßen starker
kameradschaftszwang unter diesen
Funktionären und das ist das worüber wir
eigentlich immer wir reden über Leute
wir reden über Funktionen da geht alles
mögliche aber wir reden immer über
Menschen und ich komme da nur hoch ich
komme da nur rein Teil des Systems bin
ja und deswegen wird das nie passieren
also ich hätte einen einfacher als
Modell das ich hoffe angemessen halte
die FIFA zu reduzieren auf ein
Veranstaltungsbüro für die
Fußballweltmeisterschaft also das sind
ja viele fähige Leute im
Managementbereich also im ländlichen
Bereich die sich mit diesen Dingen
auskennen ähm der der Präsident müsste
rotieren alle ein oder zwei Jahre aus
jedem Kontinentalverband zwei Jahre
maximal dann das reicht
dass er keine eigenen Strukturen in so
einer kurzen Zeit implementieren kann ja
wenn das nächste Mal sondern erst wenn
wieder dran schon klar und das würde
vollkommen Reich wir brauchen die FIFA
für nichts
anderes.ich ich ich frage mich schon
seit Jahren immer wieder ob man
möglicherweise an der Tatsache one
country one vote ob man daran mal
dringend was ändern müsste also alle
haben sozusagen das gleiche Gewicht ist
völlig egal woher du kommst das hat er
zum Teil völlig absurde auswirksam also
ich würde mal die These wagen wenn jetzt
so ein Verband wieder DFB der so groß
und so einflussreich ist wenn die mehr
Einfluss auch dann in der Vergabe bei
diesen ominösen Stimmabgaben und so
weiter hätten dann hättest du doch da
auch eine ganz andere Situation dann
wäre es doch nicht so wie es jetzt ist
das stimmt doch wenn Länder mit die
haben die überhaupt
amerikan ja ich meine Trinidad und
Tobago glaube ich ne ursprünglich die
spielen schon Fußball aber man kann das
natürlich nicht vergleichen von von
wir wissen wie viele Inselstaaten gibt
es denn allein im Südpazifik die mit
beschäftigt sind nicht unterzugehen
wegen das Klima richtig ja Problematik
die haben also nicht das Problem jetzt
noch irgendwo ein Fußballplatz neben dem
einen der da vielleicht existiert noch
hinzubauen ja stimmt die sitzen
auch so oder das ist ähm
Mitglieder die sind nicht aus allen
Ländern aber aber zum Teil auch aus
vielen Ländern ohne große
leichtathletikultur
redet jedes Land egal ob du ein Fußball
Hintergrund hast ob du eine Liege hast
ob du ein Platz hast und ein schöner
Sandstreifen der Karibik wunderbar zum
Urlaub machen da gibt's keine profiliger
wo die Stadien voll sind ja geht gar
nicht weiter die Leute nicht da sind
aber haben genauso eine Stimme im
Parlament wie ähm
genau
Großbritannien oder von Frankreich oder
Brasilien sagt das gleiche
7, ich glaube 2 Millionen organisierte
Mitglieder im DFB werden
überstimmt von goham und Guinea wenn man
deinen Reformvorschlag oder deinen
veränderungssitzer mehr zum
Reformvorschlag folgen will und dass man
die FIFA viel kleiner macht und dass man
quasi auf die organisationskompetenz
begrenzt dann hast du ja überzeugen
dargelegt dass das von ihnen nicht geht
da gibt es so viele Leute die jetzt von
dem System profitieren das kaum einer
Interesse daran hat und wenn er dir viel
Präsident jetzt die Chance hat auch noch
bei der FIFA einen schönen Posten zu
kriegen was auch noch gut bezahlt ist
und so weiter warum soll er das nicht
tun ja warum soll er dann so eisern sein
und sagt mit diesen Leuten will ich
nichts zu tun habe ich treten beim
Verband aus der FIFA raus aber das war
ja das was eigentlich passieren müsste
weil es ja von ihnen nicht reformierbar
ist ich komme also zum dritten Mal
darauf zurück ohne Austritt aus der FIFA
scheint mir das Ganze nicht zu gehen das
ist dann die ultimeration wenn wir einen
an einen geordneten Übergang halbwegs
dort wäre auch nicht geordnet die gehen
raus und dann muss was passiert
aber es ist würde sich zumindest im
sportlichen Umfeld abspielen ja die UEFA
müsste dann den Lied übernehmen was ist
sicherlich täte wenn sie in ihrem
eigenen Verband genügend Unterstützung
dafür hätte dass es durchaus denkbar das
andere Szenario ist das was wir vor vor
sieben Jahren schon mal erlebt hatten
und das kann sich durchaus wiederholen
dass der Staatsanwalt kommt und sagt so
wir machen jetzt Strafverfahren gegen
den FIFA-Präsidenten in dem Fall gegen
Gianni in fantino denn es laufen ja
strafsermittlungen gegen ihn in der
Schweiz schon seit ja ungefähr zwei
Jahren und wenn das umschlägt in einen
Strafverfahren also wenn die sagen okay
wir haben jetzt genug
Materialien es wird straflage erhoben
dann muss er raus jedenfalls nach dem
Toten und dann wäre natürlich ein guter
oder also man hat ja schon nach Platter
gedacht schlimmer kann es nicht werden
und dann kam Infantino ja aber die die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass jemand das
gleichen Kalibers da hochkommt der genug
Freunde hat auf die unterstützen kann ja
und die sich auf ihn stützen können ist
doch einfach groß oder nicht in mir
kommt das so ein bisschen vor wie wie im
Politbüro der alten Sowjetunion daher
also da war Gorbatschow der ganz große
Betriebsunfall und vorher waren erstmal
all die anderen Rentner dann die von
denen einer betonköpfiger war als der
andere also ich kann mir gar nicht
vorstellen dass es bei der FIFA zu einem
so positiven Betriebsunfall kommt das
ist sehr genau beobachtet und geht
strukturell gar nicht immer die Frage ob
sich ein Zeitfenster öffnet und das wäre
jetzt
gegeben weil es nämlich keine Infantino
hat alles im Griff es gibt keine starken
Leute an seiner Seite klar
genau und
in diesem Falle also wenn wenn es dazu
käme würde automatisch die die UEFA in
die starke Position rutschen auch weil
sie natürlich dann sagen könnte pass mal
auf jetzt machen wir den Spaß nicht mehr
mit wenn es einer von seinem Kumpanen da
übernimmt dann ist für uns die rote
Linie überschritten und wir sehen das
das ist ja eigentlich schon auch einmal
der Fall gewesen als die UEFA nämlich
ihren ja karlschlag an der Spitze hatte
denn die UEFA ist ja damals auch mit
kassiert worden nicht nur die FIFA
sondern der UEFA Präsident Platine
damals und es kam dann mit dem
slowenischen pfefferin einer ins Amt der
das bisher sehr gut macht sich zumindest
nicht angreifbar gemacht hat im
korruptionsbereich und einer der niemals
niemals vorgesehen war für diese
Funktion
hat mal erzählt also der hat diesen
Betrieb das Bus Nummer 5 kennengelernt
ja also wenn es wenn es dann abends zu
den ganzen Bankett geladen geht dann
gibt es nachher einen stechen unter den
Spitzen funktionieren werden den Einzel
Limousinen an 1 2 3 4 fährt und dahinter
kommt dann die brustchen oder Rest drin
sitzt und da kommst dann auch darauf an
ob man dann langsam mal von Bus 5 im Bus
1 vorigen kann also der war nie der war
nie auf der auf der Agenda Slowenien ist
jetzt auch nicht die große Fußballnation
und ähm ist also dann durch die weil man
einfach niemanden hatte wen machen wir
wenn holen war was was machen wir machen
mal so eine packsituation nehmen weil
jemand der ungefährliches profilos und
in vier Jahren stell mal was neu auf
vielleicht können wir durch den hindurch
regieren oder vielleicht setzen wir dann
bis dahin haben meine neuen gebacken und
ersetzen ungefähr der Plan und der ist
zum Glück nicht aufgegangen also
das schaut ganz gut aus bei der UEFA
Thomas mal zum Abschluss noch mal
gefragt
etwas fällt auf in der Geschichte also
da laufen über all die Jahre diese
ganzen komischen Dinge dann passiert
2010 Bill Clinton irgendwann sauer wirft
Aschenbecher durchs Hotelzimmer so wird
es zumindest erzählt die Großmacht
Amerika fühlt sich so gedemütigt dass
wir sagen sollen jetzt Rauchen wir da
mal richtig auf und das tun sie dann
auch und das geht dann so weit dass man
dann irgendwann 2015 diese berühmten
Bilder hat ja aber Menschen hinter
Bettlaken Tisch und einfach festgenommen
und danach verhaftet viele verurteilt
werden und so weiter es finden Ration
statt deswegen Verurteilungen statt
Leute wandern hinter Gitter und so
weiter
all das passiert
und dann kriegen die Amerikaner
plötzlich diese Fußballweltmeisterschaft
226 und seitdem das ist mein Eindruck
ist wieder Ruhe und Infantino regiert zu
entspannt durch man hat das Gefühl jetzt
haben die das Interesse verloren weil
das was sie eigentlich wollten haben sie
jetzt und wenn ich den Artikel den ihr
gemacht habt richtig verstehe fängt das
alles 2016 an als Gianni in fantino eine
215 eine Reise in die USA macht einen
Flug nach New York der unter falscher
Etikette deklariert irgendwo bei der
UEFA da war ja noch UEFA Vizepräsident
Generalsekretär genau falsch deklariert
wird und der Verdacht steht im Raum dass
er den gesagt hat hör mal lass mal die
FIFA in Ruhe und macht mal halblang ihr
kriegt die WM
der Verdacht steht im Raum dass er was
er massiv bestreitet dass er sich mit
irgendwelchen Vertretern der
amerikanischen Justiz auseinandergesetzt
hat mittelbar oder unmittelbar wir
wissen es nicht das können wir nicht
irgendwas gegeben haben dass sie keine
Lust mehr hatten mit voller Wucht weiter
zu machen es reicht ja die Fakten zu
sehen die Fakten sind dass die
Amerikaner gegen unter anderem damals
gegen Leute ermittelt hatten die deren
ausliefern sind auch beantragt hatten
die auch in Abwesenheit verurteilt
wurden
Marketender in Argentinien die an
solchen kickbackgeschäft mit
fernsehrichten
genau diesen Leuten gemacht hatte und
auch der hat genau dieses Profil das ist
sehr wenig die rechte verkauft ja mit
infantinos Unterschrift genau haben sie
es gekauft und die haben das die rechte
sehr viel teurer dann weiter für
dreifache weiterverkauft für mehr als
dreifache weiterverkauft und das ist ja
zumindest mein Muster auf dass man
anspringen könnte und das ist aber nach
außen nie geschehen und erst als als wir
damals die Panama papers im Zuge der
Panama papers auf diese Zahlung gestoßen
sind weil sie dummerweise über Panama
gelaufen ist Überfall noch völlig
anderen Seite
in das Ding reingekommen und haben das
dann veröffentlicht und schlagartig hat
also die die die Schweizer Justiz der
eng mit der mit den Amerikanern die
eigentlich bei den Amerikanern
angebunden war zu der Zeit ähm
schlagartig waren die da haben eine
Razzia gemacht hatten uns aber gesagt ja
das wussten wir schon den Vertrag sie
hätten nur irgendetwas in diesem Artikel
noch drin gefunden was ihn jetzt
sozusagen die letzte Sicherheit gegeben
hätte dass sie dazu geschlagen das ist
natürlich in dem Artikel war nichts drin
was wenn ich von diesem Vertrag weiß ja
jetzt den Auslöser gibt für eine
rational schon gar nicht so schnell man
muss ja sehen wie schnell Ratze sind das
muss ja das ist nicht wie im Fernsehen
weil
muss man auch dazu sagen weil immer sehr
sehr zahm also das ist glaube ich noch
sehr wohlwollend formuliert ein oder
anderen zwischen dem Staatsanwalt Herr
Lauber der
Bundesanwalt bundesstaatsanwalts genau
ein oder andere Mal mit Infantino
getroffen hat zum Austausch und dass das
auch so Sachen sind die in den
offiziellen Akten irgendwo auftauchen
die sind zum einen nie aufgetaucht und
zum anderen
haben sie ihr letztes Treffen
komplett vergessen
mit dem Zug nach Bern die treffen sich
gehen in das Hotel Schweizer Hof in
einen Sitzungszimmer das reiner Zufall
direkt an die katarische Botschaft
angrenzt das Hotel gehört Katha Garage
Botschafter
und alle vier können sich nicht
Generalbundesanwalt ein FIFA-Präsident
und weitere Staatsanwalt und
der Sprecher des Generalbundesanwalts
können sich nicht ändern also kollektive
teilnahmenmusik
sehr seltenes Phänomen mittlerweile ist
das natürlich auch ein Thema dass die
zentrales Thema dass die
Staatsanwaltschaft in der Schweiz seine
Hoffnung dass Infantino über diese Dinge
wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr unterdrückbar
sind und nicht mehr unter den Teppich
gekehrt werden können fallen könnte
damit es ein Neuanfang der FIFA gibt
auch schon wieder zehn Jahre hinziehen
und am Ende kommt nichts mehr raus na ja
wenn wenn er viele dann dann wäre der
Weg frei für eine neue anfangen das ist
ja klar die Frage ist wie lange das geht
das kann nicht mehr so lange es geht ja
schon seit zwei Jahren die stehen auch
unter Druck sicher seine Neuwahl an oder
ja aber die diesen Selbstläufer jetzt
sind wir wieder im in der FIFA würde
nichts passieren ja
das hat er schon alles eingetütet da
gibt es schon die die ganzen Briefchen
von den Verbänden die das ganz toll
finden was geleistet hat gibt es gegen
Kandidaten das ist das Problem und das
muss man auch den Europäern Anlassen
europäischen Gegenkandidaten
ich glaube das Problem ist genau keine
Problem ist es gäbe viele Funktionäre
die sowas gerne machen würden ja aber
da laufen ehrlich gesagt jede Menge
Pfeifen rum die nicht in der Lage sind
hier wirklich gegen zu halten Punkt 1
Punkt 2 läuft es ja in der Tat so dass
du als Präsident umlangen Hebel sitzt du
besuchst eben diese ganzen kleinen und
kleinste Länder die du da hast zur Not
Hausnummer ein bisschen was drauf Nummer
500.000 pro Jahr also wenn wenn wenn ich
ein Verband habe also du machst noch
eine ganze Reihe von treffen an die du
dich später nicht erinnern kannst
überall in der Welt ich muss das ich
muss nicht jeden persönlich besuchen
nein ich habe ja auch meine Leute ich
habe da ein ganzes Team das ja auch
zuständig ist und also das ist gut
vorstellbar wie es wie es funktioniert
und der andere kann ja nur kommen und
kann machen also was immer der bietet
also
die einzige Hoffnung also es gibt ja es
gab ja drei jetzt finde ich das
zusammenfasse da das eine ist
Reformprozess von der FIFA von innen da
sagst du passiert zu 100% nicht absolut
ne der zweite war wichtige nationale
Verbände treten aus und bringen die FIFA
in einen unhaltbare Situation sagst du
wünschenswert aber
dafür dass er
eine Frage macht und das dritte ja es
wäre machbar aber du glaubst nicht dass
sie sich trauen und das dritte wäre die
Staatsanwaltschaft lässt bei Infantino
nicht locker und da müsste man sich die
Frage stellen wenn man bisher mit
Ausnahme in Amerikaner aber die
Schweizer Staatsanwalt zum Beispiel
immer so zahnbar warum sollte sich das
auf einmal ändern genau Thomas dank dir
sehr das war spannend das zu hören
empfehle noch mal wirklich mit mit
Nachdruck dass du sie dieses exzellente
dosier über die FIFA und dieses missing
link sozusagen die Rolle der USA das war
bis dahin nicht so wirklich bekannt ist
es
atemberaubend was ihr da herausgefunden
habt und das andere die Rolle dieser
Schiedsrichter im dunklen Keller auch
darüber habt ihr und werdet ihr weiter
berichten das soll sehr bald erscheinen
auf jeden Fall während also spannend wir
sind gespannt Thomas danke dir Richard
danke dir
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]